dass das dann halt ein bisschen es hallo
und herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
folge ich habe mir gedacht ich nehme
wieder so ganz wiki will ich einfach nur
wunderbar war weil ich hab mir gedacht
das hatten wir schon so was von sauer
fucking lange nicht mehr einfach dass
wir so etwas gezockt haben einfach so
petros gezockt haben mehr oder weniger
und zwar sonst immer die ganze sache
nicht alle sind so ja ich bin gar nicht
genehmigt ich gehe mal daraus so ich
habe jetzt nickname angeblich hoffe das
passiert auch hier ist perfekt 8 mal 1
map auf caravan ag jetzt mal rein machen
start- und jetzt bin ich da immer noch
als contractor drin aber ich weiß nicht
ob ich jetzt erkennt na ja ich habe mir
einfach so gedacht die sonst die sachen
die ich sonst irgendwie so hoch laden am
tumen bin sind halt meistens irgendwie
sowas wie fexco mahnten eine mod mal
kräftige den marines mal da und dann hab
ich mir einfach gedacht ja komm ich
könnte ja auch mal wieder rein
theoretisch so ganz billig sondern alte
pvp runde einfach bringen weil das war
so was was sich auch viele gewünscht
hatten so ein spiel noch mal wieder
einfach schillig pvp das kam mir schon
lange nicht mehr und so war auch hier
schreibt wieder in den chat conny kann
sein dass ich doch nicht genug bin
es ist mega crazy gerade euro steht auch
immer und crafter acht mann ich weiß
eine freundin ist jetzt auch egal ich
hoffe einfach dass es klappt das sieht
richtig gut aus mit dem shader weil das
alles so ein bisschen nämlich ist ich
weiß der ein oder andere pvp kühlen ich
würde jetzt ja sagen du kannst dich man
dann mit dem change erinnern weil
ich jetzt einfach mal eben screenshot
machen wir das sieht einfach mega schön
aus auch der typ da vorne das nicht
erbaut jetzt hier über das war sehr sehr
sehr sehr traurig
und er hat schon einen stock auch fakt
wenn ich jetzt sterbe dann ist aber ende
im gelände freunde dann ist er richtig
ende im gelände hier das da hab ich
jetzt aber überhaupt keine lust hier
drauf gerade eben
natürlich können wir mal eben hier
sollen
doch nicht wahr sein dass ich direkt
beim bett verliere roman slater nein
nein er mich gesehen
fakt aber electrum wie sonstwas alter
scheiße da habe ich ja gerade das kann
doch nicht wahr sein ist er der ist
runtergefallen ok stark er hat mich
irgendwie noch am leben lassen ich weiß
nicht wieso oder was er gemacht hat oder
hatte überhaupt nicht abgebaut
ja er hat auf jeden fall abgebaut
scheiße dass er sich auch direkt über
bord sind die größten randys na ja ich
werde jetzt eben verbessert und zwar
habe ich mir gedacht ja komm luca hier
kannst du mal irgendwie wieder so eine
chillige damalig damalig öfters
hochgeladene folge etwas bringen und da
wollte ich auch ein kleines thema
ansprechen und zwar mache ich mir
gedanken über so ein paar serien die man
irgendwie bringen kann oder so etwas
interessantes und da habe ich letztens
mit dem was habt ihr gesehen habe ich
hochgeladen eine folge wer bin ich war
das und die kamen mega gut an und dann
habe ich mir gedacht da kommt jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal gerade ein typ das
ist auf jeden fall sehr sehr geil da ich
bin tot ich bin ich bin tot ich bin ein
fucking fahrt soll ich war zumindest
nicht der letzte
also der erste letzte keine ahnung er
sieht sehr schön aus
egal wenn man natürlich direkt ohne ihr
wissen freunde werden genug in die
kommentare schreibt ist einfach nur
jemand der recht hatte
nicht zocken sw gleicht das ja auch hier
so mega zelten hoch einfach und zwar
habe ich mir gedanken macht über ein
konzept
wer bin ich gibt es natürlich schon aber
jetzt wer bin ich
in minecraft also dass man wirklich so
irgendwie beispielsweise weil sie nicht
man fragt dann so mich packt eine
hintergrund irgendwie eine runde
irgendwie wo wir zocken oder irgendwie
so wird dann irgendwie im hintergrund
eine runde packen wo wir irgendwie weiß
nicht so beispielsweise etwas zocken
oder so was in die richtung und dann
noch in den vordergrund hat dann einfach
meine fans von mir und von der person
mit der ich zocke halt mit der ich das
spiel halt spiele und da spielen dann
halt zu minecraft wer bin ich also dass
wir dann quasi wirklich so minecraft
sachen nehmen also ich so was man kann
am anfang fragen so scheiße ich bin so
schlecht in diesem modus m ein mann mann
mann mann das man halt am anfang also
fragen stellt ja bis zum blog und dann
nein und dann geht der andere damit
fragen dann sei ja bist du ein server
oder soja bis zum deutschen servern
das wird anderen jahr kann man auch bei
dem bett wars spielen oder blöd wenn ich
werde etwas auf amerikanischen servern
zocken kann
ihr wisst aber denke ich was ich meine
und so also darüber ich meine gedanken
macht sowas finde ich eigentlich ganz
cool als so konzept einfach das ist dann
halt auch so öfters mal kommt ich weiß
nicht und da wollte ich halt erstmal
euch fragen weil ich auch heute bei
twitter gepostet hatte ja was wollt ihr
ja scheiße geld aufgebaut bekommen das
ist nicht wahr ich wollte es gerade
einbauen ich scheiße dass das dann halt
ein bisschen öfter da springe ich genau
in dieses ding rein es ist doch nicht
war es soll einfach nicht sein so
schlecht wie ich bin
mann mann mann mann mann mann mann willi
play du musst jetzt irgendwie reißen
hier also einfach so minecraft wer bin
ich quasi würde ich das dann einfach
nennen so ganz simpel ich weiß nicht was
er davon halten würde vielleicht sagt er
es gibt schon mit billigen das land
schon so viele aber minecraft bin ich
hab ich jetzt zum beispiel ich noch nie
gesehen vielleicht gibt es das ja auch
schon keine ahnung da könnt ihr
bedenklich mehr darüber sagen aber an
ich hatte ich mir halt gedacht das ist
vielleicht ein ganz interessante idee
wollte ich erst heute hochladen
allerdings funktioniert mein teamspeak
nicht wenn ihr da auch irgendwelche
ideen habt würde ich mich auch freuen
über lösungsvorschläge und zwar ich habe
schon alles probiert teamfähig neu
installiert und alles mögliche gemacht
router rausgezogen wieder we started und
letztlich alles bc neustadt alles
gemacht funktioniert irgendwie nicht
keine ahnung woran das liegt irgendwie
ich komme auf keinen teamspeak server
mehr drauf ich wollte es heute
eigentlich schon aufnehmen aber ich habe
jetzt angedacht kommen einmal hier eine
simple runde wo ich etwas locker und
einfach mal frage was überhaupt davon
haltet weil es kann ja auch sein da die
jetzt sagt wie ich vorhin schon gesagt
haben macht es nicht stinkt nach
scheffeln und so also keine ahnung
bleibe ich halt auf eure meinung
angewiesen weil letztendlich hätte bock
darauf ich denke ich wäre doch mal eine
folge davon bringt damit ihr dann so
sehen werden wie das ganze in etwa so
aussehen wie auch etliche schilder
sondern achtmal einsacken map freunde
jetzt erstmal hier das wichtigste was
ich vorhin auch schon gesehen habe das
wichtigste ist es am anfang das bett
einzubauen so nur noch ein bisschen dazu
lernen hier dann ist natürlich jetzt
auch hier wieder so eine sache
können wir natürlich recht schnell mal
eben zu bauen hier alles da dies nehme
ich meine lieben freunde get the most
important thing pflege ich da mal zu
sagen das bett einzubauen ist schon eine
wichtige sache
um erfolgreich in vétroz zu spielen und
jetzt können wir uns nämlich mal um die
mitte kümmern dass wir da mal hin laufen
an dem ich dann natürlich auch ich
kollidieren nehme ich mir dann natürlich
auch direkt eine kleine rüstung mit und
einen stock um da so ein paar leute zu
boxen einfach so jetzt sollen uns hier
noch im ring stockhieben und knüppel sag
jetzt mal eben schnell das eisen hier
auch ich kann mir sogar direkten
sportlichen hohe perfekt so freunde wir
sind schon ganz schön auch gut
aufgestellt die für den staat würde ich
mal grob behaupten
ich freue mich jetzt mal hier im rüber
und hoffe einfach dass die da hinten
noch kein gold haben jetzt nämlich
keiner sich zum ich rüber baut und dann
versuche ich hier schon mal das erste
bild abzubauen
also ganz großes thema einfach heute ja
minecraft wer bin ich was haltet ihr von
der idee ist es mir einfach so beim
einscannen oder beim schweißen oder beim
duschen oder irgendwo gekommen weil sie
nicht da kommen wir immer so
irgendwelche den felgen welche serien
und ich habe gedacht das gibt's doch
nicht vielleicht interessiert einfach
wer bin ich mit lukas kamen ganz gut an
bei euch deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ja da kommt man ja was mit minecraft
machen weil hier ja sehr viele leute
doch wegen minecraft hier abonnenten des
kanals sind
ich habe keine spitzhacke das war auf
jeden fall ein fehler als ein bett doch
gar nicht eingebaut der von grün dann
ist grün jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
schon mal raus ich spiele auch mit
shader das ist auch ein bisschen doof
sind aber einfach aussieht schöne aus
mit shader ne weile mal wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal auf dem neuen klicken
würde ja dann dann läuft zwar viel
besser also für euch wahrscheinlich
genau gleich weil ich ja 30 fps
eingestellt habe aber ja ich kann das
auch weiter schauen und so weit alles
aber naja ich glaube ich dass es jetzt
erstmal so ohne shader ja also was
haltet ihr von der idee schreibt er vom
eure meinung in die kommentare hier ist
ja ein bürger aber das liegt
wahrscheinlich am text schmeckt einfach
und dass das von pink wurde zerstört ich
dachte schon ihren film ton und freunde
so langsam müssen wir hier eigentlich
auch mal in die mitte gehen
wegen den wegen gold et cetera pp da
hinten ist so ein komischer du scheiße
wie soll ich das denn jetzt machen
ich weiß überhaupt nicht wie ich
irgendwie übergehen soll ich dachte mal
wird uran abgebaut
freundlich haben planen ich freue mich
einfach so nach oben wieder so wie ich
das letzte mal gemacht habe mit der
taktik war ja ganz erfolgreich und also
zumindest nicht letzte mal nicht und
dann werde ich mich jetzt erstmal hier
die mitte bauen um zu schauen was das
ganze hier mit sich bringt ich habe
immer angst dass irgendwie mich jetzt
irgendwer mit einem bogen runtergeht
weil dieser zweite kraft hd ist auf
jeden fall schon richtig gut dabei mit
seiner killstreak der unimo freunde sie
gold ja ja hier ist ein bisschen geheult
ich brauche ich nur vier stück und wie
viel habe ich fünf costa von mani matter
auf [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] nein du steht wenig
an eine pizza nein nein nein lassen
wenigstens noch das gold mitnehmen alter
das kann doch nicht sein
scheiße
wo kann ich ihn ist schon raus der login
entspannt sitzt allerdings nicht ein
bogen einer neuen filmstadt richtig
scheiße weil ich so lange nicht mehr bei
meiner eigenen base weiter könnte sich
ja jetzt einfach hinbauen bitte es kommt
mehr charakter her und es kamen
hinterher und jetzt meine lieben freunde
wird sich hier selbstverständlich der op
bogen geholt soll name den bogen am
start dann noch hier eben ein pfeil hohe
mit der unendlichkeit geht das ja klar
so perfekt jetzt haben uns noch ebenen
trank und jetzt wird bisschen aufgeräumt
achten schwert könnte ich mir auch noch
holen
meine freunde auf 5 gold bei euch dafür
das kriege ich hin
ich hole mir noch eben schnell hier
einen trank
das kann ich mit an der hollager hab ich
einen trank der direkt heilung nehme ich
mir mal mit dann kauf ich mir mal ein
paar hier so ein 23 würden eigentlich
klar gehen und tippte totalität
irgendwelche extras hätte ich jetzt
gerade noch betroffenen ändert es bringt
ja auch nix diese kühe hätte ich gern
sophia sofia horn nö mein bett wurde
abgebaut
aber ok freuen
ihr habt so gebäude ist hab ich auf
jeden fall einmal mehr sterben deshalb
die letzte runde für diese aufnahme ich
mal wir sind einmal 14 minuten weil ich
auch noch fast runter aber eben noch
hier schnell das gold graben
der dude ist das gold am graben team
bienen seien so ist hier noch irgendwo
was liegt auch nicht so und jetzt weiß
nicht was ist da noch nicht abgebaut
schwarz schwarzes brett ist auf jeden
fall nicht abgebaut und ich meine auch
dahinter ist gerade doch dahinter ist
einer scheiße bin ich denn in jeder pvp
situation ob man aber egal meine lieben
freunde ich habe angesprochen was ich
ansprechen wollte und ja ich gesagt
finde ich will kämpfen vps laden das
politische hin und so kommen
normalerweise wenn der plan gewesen ich
will hier so drüber am bahndamm lauf
zudem hier ziemlich olle hat natürlich
mit kisten zugebaut ist natürlich klug
aber naja ich würde sagen es euch
gefallen meine lieben freunde dann würde
ich mich definitiv über eine positive
wertung freundliches ein klick jeden und
dann auf jeden fall eure meinung zu dem
projekt in die kommentare schreiben was
ihr davon haltet und dann sehen uns in
einem nächsten video wieder hast du hier
ich muss noch jemand meine tollen hier